But my uncle.
So he had this house in Utah and he wasn't there and his
mom was there and she was there with her friends.
And this was in the tooth early two thousands.
And she called my uncle from Utah
and he was in LA I think. And she was like, Hey,
so my friends and I sat down to finally start watching the Sopranos.
Is it usually this graphic? And my uncle said, well,
it's a pretty, pretty graphic show. Yeah. People get killed and stuff.
And she was like, no, I'm talking about the sex. And he was like, uh,
I mean, sometimes there's sex scenes in and Oh yeah. And he's like, yeah,
but it's really like, that's all it is. And he was like,
what are you talking about? It's not just sex. Like,
there's just like, Oh my God. She says,
I'm watching this support knows.
She ordered.
Heard a porn called this support knows instead.
Dude.
First of all, so old woman,
you know, thought she was watching the Sopranos, turned it on.
People were but each other.
And then she realized after calling someone while people,
while people were onscreen,
but that she was watching the supporters instead look
at the supporters thing, look at that.
And then they made the supporters to up.
And of course they made some pornos four and five dude.
How about how many sequels they make for pornos? They don't give a.
That's how that's how much, you know, storylines don't matter. You know
that they just keep making sequels.
Like they can't even make eight seasons of game of Thrones without people
and it's, and then they'll just be like, it'll be like this support. I was 95.
I mean, dude, look at how gross,
how dumb are guys that they'll just see it. And they'll be like, ah,
look at that one up there on the upper right. Dude.
Support those to look at the guy on unreal dude.
James D did you did your Joe's of course
danger, Georgia. D James did Georgia. Hey dude, James did Georgia.
You know, for sake,
James did Georgia Dame.
J how do you say that James did Georgia. Hi,
I'm James did Georgia and go yourself. Pick it, pick a different one.
The support owes three and the guy on it, dude,
the only more Italian you could be by the it then actually acting in the
Sopranos is taking your Dick out. You know? And that's what these guys do.
The most Italian you could be is in a silk,
buttoned down,
opened up thing with a hairy chest and a chain and a cigar with
sunglasses on and your pants are down and your out. And you say, Hey,
you guys get over here and you're talking to like permed out white
chicks. You want me to suck your?
Hey, you's guys get over here. Hi,
Tony wants me to suck his again. All right.
I'll do it.
Look after the lasagna on the stove, I got to suck. Tony's
support knows, you know,
like do it support knows wha
like send not clever dude. The sex,
uh, the sex things. It'd be like, don't even try. They'll be like,
yeah, but you know, we've got to make the sex vendors, right?
Yeah. We got to make the com vendors.
It's between the sex vendors and the com vendors.
We've got iron man, and captain, Dick America.
They're like, okay, sure.
And then we got who's the who's the Charlotte.
Who's the, why was forget her name? The one is married. Colin Jost,
Joseph Scarlet Johanson, her character. We're just going to call her girl.
We don't even know her name in the thing. Black widow. We'll call her.
It's all good.
And then iron, man. We'll call Hawk Hawk,
but it'll be about his. You know, his Cox Hawk is Kako get big and green,
right? He'll say he'll he'll. I just have a big and it'll,
it'll get big and green. And then some girl, and then will be like, Oh,
not your big green. And then she'll be into it and.
And she'll suck as big green. Right.
Then we'll have a Nebula. We'll call her Mula.
Yeah.
Then Thanos we'll call them big balls, Thanos or something. Just big balls.
We'll call them big balls and a have big purple balls.
And we'll put the infinity stones on his balls. This is the for real.
And they don't even try. And then they're done with the meeting and then, uh,
and then we got Spiderman. We'll call him. Guzzler come, he'll be gay.
Call him, come guzzle, man, go back.
Then we'll go to a Nick fury.
You guessed it. You guess what? We'll call him. And of course, I mean,
do we even need to say it? Let's all. Say it on the count of three, three, two,
one Dick fury grade. We all said it. Of course. There we go.
We'll put an eye patch over his left balls, uh,
star, uh, Dr. Strange. We'll call him Dr. Com.
Dr. Let's go on Dr. GEs.
And then when he GEs it'll open up a portal and then girl will get into it.
Go to more to the left. Uh, who else? We got rocket raccoon.
We got low key Bucky Barnes. We'll call them come. One, two, three, come one,
come two and come three
black Panther. We'll call them black Panther.
Groot. We'll call him rude.
I mean, dude, what is,
I didn't realize the Asian guy's name is Wong Wong. S racist.
That's his name in the Avengers. A Wong.
Okay. Why does it say Wong Wong or Benedict?
Wong is playing Wong. Oh, wow. Okay. Well, they were like, warned me.
We've got to get him right. Also, dude,
I love when Asian guys are named like Ben Benedict,
yanked foolin.
[Inaudible].
When I was a kid,
I went to school with so many Asian kids and their names would be like the old,
the old American names that people don't use anymore. Like George and Hank,
it will be like Hank suck. And we'd be like, Hey man, you know,
at least pick Charlie or,
uh, Dave, you know, they would be like,
the girls would be Mary and grace and the guys would be George
and Hank.